[Applause]
nine months ago the overwhelming
majority of chileans voted to allow 155
delegates to form the world's first
constitutional convention with gender
parity and that promised to address
modern-day challenges like protecting
the environment
many predicted it would become a global
reference
but with less than three months left to
finish drafting the proposed
constitution things aren't looking quite
so good
it cannot be that they want to
expropriate our pension funds or our
houses they do not protect us from
anything
all they care about is changing the
national anthem our emblem and our flag
in actual fact none of these things have
been approved by the convention
nor the belief by many that parents
won't have a say in their children's
education that indigenous groups will
form 12 independent countries and that
farmers won't be able to kill their
animals
but it is an extraordinarily complex
process in which every delegate has a
voice even to make sometimes absurd
proposals that are eventually dismissed
and it's become even more confusing
thanks to misinformation campaigns that
are spreading on social media
a new study reveals that 60 of chileans
have received false information about
the convention
and we detected that 30 of these people
shared this false news it wasn't
necessarily on purpose but if you
believe what you read and think it's
relevant you share that information
without verifying it
as a result three new polls suggest that
chilean's support has plummeted for a
new constitution that 80 percent had
hoped would lay the groundwork for a
more equal and just society
even before the convention has finished
drafting the majority of articles
the idea here is to distribute power
more evenly we always knew that those
who hold power don't want to lose it and
the mainstream media which is owned by
major economic groups isn't neutral when
it comes to covering the convention
chile's mainstream media is mostly
conservative but it's in fact the social
media that has the most impact according
to european union experts
false information or disinformation
spreads six times faster than real news
often times because of misleading
headlines that have nothing to do with
the body of the story
rectifying or neutralizing
misinformation is far more difficult and
is turning out to be a major challenge
for what may be the first constitution
written under the influence of this new
technological age
lucian newman al jazeera santiago